i think you would i don't think you need
to learn how to code and be good at it i
think that you just need to learn enough
so that you're not scared of computers
so that you don't and you know if you
sit in front of a computer and open a
terminal window or some program crashes
you're not you're not like wow this is
some mysterious black box object i don't
quite understand how it works it's good
to understand how it works because then
you can just use it better and as i
mentioned at the beginning of this
conversation
you know it's the most powerful tool
ever invented by humanity so knowing how
to use it will give you leverage like
nothing else even if even if you
never need to use a computer in your job
let's say that you're you know
let's just say you're in some other
profession eventually you want to get
the word out you want to talk to people
so whether you want to use periscope or
twitter knowing computers will actually
teach you
and let you know even how to spread your
message you'll be a better user of
periscope you'll be a better user of
twitter yeah by the way my incompetence
with the microphones notwithstanding
believe it or not i am actually pretty
good with computers